we think you're one of the cutest
creations ever boo and you're also one
of the most intriguing
there are paused moments and monsters
Inc that reveal amazing links to other
Disney and Pixar movies and there's a
pause moment and brave that has led to
the most fascinating theory these ideas
about who you grow up to be are
mind-blowing and they'll change the way
fans think about you and those movies
forever Disney movies are packed with
the Easter eggs that are so easy to miss
but pause at just the right moment and
you'll find some amazing revelations
that will change the way you think about
your favorite characters you know I'm
coming
[Music]
keep watching to the end to discover how
we were given clues about frozen two
years before it was released Elsa's
princess filled coronation Elsa's
coronation is filled with royal guests
as you'd expect but there are a few very
recognizable Disney Princesses when you
pause the scene you can spot Cinderella
Tiana and Rapunzel and blink and you'll
miss it moments pretty cool right stay
tuned for more amazing pause moments and
frozen Bambi's mom lives on we were all
so sad when Bambi's mother met her end
in the 1942 movie but that wasn't the
last we saw of her remember the scene
when Bambi's mom looks up from eating
grass moments before the hunter finds
her that pose is reused in the Jungle
Book
and again in the rescuers during the
song someone's waiting for you and again
in a hunting scene in the sword in the
stone so she lived on in the Disney
verse Indies pause moments your mother
can't be with you anymore
the real second star to the right have
you ever wondered about the two stars at
the beginning of the Walt Disney
Pictures intro we find out who they are
in a pause moment in The Princess and
the Frog
after Rey the Firefly passes his friends
see him appear as a second star next to
his love Evangeline they looked just
like the second star to the right in the
1953 movie Peter Pan how sweet is that
Belle can time travel we all know Belle
loves to read but did you know the
heroine of Beauty and the Beast can also
travel back in time I'm free in a pause
moment during the Hunchback of Notre Dom
you can spot Belle walking through the
streets of Paris her nose is stuck in a
book naturally both movies are set in
France but the Hunchback story is set in
1482 and Beauty and the Beast takes
place in the 18th century
Gaston's fate is written in his eyes
sticking with Beauty and the Beast
there's a paused moment in the 1991
movie that seals gaston's fate pause
when the villain plummets from the top
of beasts castle and you'll see skulls
flash in his eyes if you doubted what
happened to him after he fell hundreds
of feet into the ravine now you know for
sure that it was game over for Gaston
scar second life what happened to scar
after his demise in the 1994 movie the
banking the answers in the movie
Hercules when Hercules is having his
portrait painted he's wearing a lion's
pelt in mythology this is the Nemean
lion but when Hercules throws it on the
ground it looks at just like scar the
lead animator was the same person for
both Hercules and Skaar so it makes
sense and early in Lion King Azaz who
jokes that Skaar would make a very
handsome throw rug boo the witch in
brave there's a blink and you'll miss it
moment where Merida enters the witch's
Hut look real close and you'll see a
wood carving of Sully from monsters Inc
this is one of the reasons that film
writer John Negroni came up with the
theory that all Pixar films exist in the
same universe he deduced that boo grew
up to be the witch in brave boos related
to Andy sticking with boo there's also a
theory that she might be related to Andy
from Toy Story and it's all down to a
pause moment in boos bedroom zoom in and
you'll see a Jessie doll from Toy Story
2 fans have speculated that boob grew up
to be Andy's mom the original owner of
Jessie boo has other recognizable toys -
there's the ball from luxo jr.
and a Finding Nemo squeeze toy we like
this theory better than the which one
what are you gonna do with these toys
should we donate him to Sunnyside Anna
is really strong fans cheered when Anna
punched Hans and frozen we could tell
she was pretty strong as the villain
flew right into the water
but if you pause that moment you'll see
just how strong Anna is her fist goes
right into Hans eye socket the force is
strong with this one frozen - in
Zootopia we had to wait six years for
the sequel to frozen but Disney must
have been planning it for quite some
time after all there's a big clue in a
pause moment from Zootopia did you
notice two floats in - amongst Dukes
bootleg movies we should have known all
along well well look who it is the duke
of bootleg if you love learning
little-known facts about disney you'll
love being subscribed to the things
channel turn on post notifications to be
the first to watch our latest videos if
you're watching on your phone or tablet
be sure to turn on notifications in your
YouTube settings which paused moment is
your favorite let us know in the
comments please give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see
next time thanks for watching